foreign
to dance has broken out at this rally in
New Delhi the song comes from the
western state of Rajasthan one of the
many regions represented here
thousands of farmers from across India
have gathered to demand the government
lower taxes on fertilizers and other
agriculture equipment and increase
financial support
we want prices that earn us a profit
right now we are not recovering our
costs we are buried deep in debt for
three generations we have only been
passing on debts
the sectors reeling from multiple crises
including extreme weather patterns and
reduced output this demonstration was
called by a union with close ties to the
governing BJP it comes months after
Farmers ended a year-long protest
against Three Laws they said left them
worse off and benefited big corporations
how many prime minister Narendra Modi
finally revoked the legislation in
November 2021. Rising
earlier this year the government set up
a committee to address their concerns
some units have called these meetings
insincere and have boycotted them
committee members say they're
considering a combination of policies to
resolve long-standing issues ultimately
we have to remember one thing for Farmer
it is the his crucial concern is the
bottom line what is he getting out of
there so we have to ensure that farming
remains viable for him
without losing sight of these other
objectives that natural resource
degradation and and also the
agricultural growth and food security
most Indians live in rural areas and
nearly half the working population makes
a living from agriculture analysts say
policies need to be more inclusive so I
think constant dialogue
but not think at the national level
think at the local level think at the
regional level state governments need to
be involved local level activists need
to be involved and Farmers leaders need
to be trusted as as stakeholders rather
than as as people who are who are only
disruptors India will hold a general
election in 16 months and some observers
say it could give Farmers the upper hand
in negotiations
New Delhi